any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
hey everybody welcome my name is brian
keating i am the co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at uc san diego
and i'm the host of today's into the
impossible podcast
uh and it's such a treat to a welcome a
writer
a thinker and intellectual whose work
i've admired admired for years and not
just in the written or the
uh or the visual domain but also her
work in creating uh
just a spectacular human being which uh
she
nucleated uh long ago uh and that's
sasha sagan so this is the first time
we've had a parent and a child on the
into the impossible podcast and such a
delight to have you following up on
sasha's mother's day podcast
we're welcoming andrea to the podcast
today ann how are you doing
i'm doing really well and i'm so happy
to be with you brian
and uh i'm honored to share
a podcast with my darling sasha
she really is and i made the point uh at
some point
or another that uh that sasha and i kind
of talked a little bit about that
your granddaughter you know spent some
time in you i
i have a i have a feeling a philosophy
that or at least uh maybe it's a
non-totally non-scientific hunch but
i always feel like the um the maternal
grandmother
is somehow closer to the grandkids i
mean don't tell this to your you know
in-laws or whatever but
but the fact is that at one when sasha
was born
she had within her the egg that would
become elena right and that
egg was inside of you and i just think
it's so wonderful that you had this
beautiful connection
uh as we were talking just before we
started uh about these possible worlds
and and the worlds that we create and
and i want to
you know the occasion of this of this
discussion is on the
um on the occasion of your book cosmos
possible worlds which i've read
and listened to on audiobook and first
of all i want to always start as i do
with all my authors
i always ignore the advice to not judge
a book by its cover
i judge all books brother covers at
least at some level
and i had this discussion with sasha and
now i want to have it with you
um what is the genesis if you will
permit me of of the cover and the title
and the subtitle and
of course is part of a series but can
you walk us through um
how the series what your vision for the
series was and how this particular cover
and subtitle came to be
well these are great questions uh
my vision for this series was to
tell the stories of our ancestors
who also had their backs to the wall
but also to acknowledge the current
danger
and yet to inspire with the hope
of the future that we can still have if
we only get our
act together if we begin to use our
powers
our science and high technology with
wisdom
and foresight and consideration
for the generations of life to come on
this world
and so that was you know i know that we
all know
there's this big shadow on our future
and our kids
definitely know it and i feel it in them
and so in order to be able to look them
in the eye and
to feel like i was doing something i
wanted
not only to acknowledge that reality but
also
to envision what the world could be like
so the title
possible worlds came to me because i was
thinking
of the possible worlds most obviously of
the exoplanets
the newly discovered recently discovered
planets
that orbit other stars but then i was
also thinking
about the worlds that have existed on
this world
that are now lost to us the lost
civilizations
of which we know so very little as well
as
the lost worlds of our ancestors the
lost
worlds of the searchers the generations
of searchers
whose courage whose
innovation has really
built the foundation of our society
and ultimately my my focus
was the possible world that this world
can become and then in a more personal
way
i was thinking of the world
that is made possible by love
by the experience of love by being loved
as a child as an adult
and what that can do to you how that can
change you
and open you up to greater possibilities
so
those were all the thoughts now the
cover is
a ring nebula and
what i wanted to do with it was to give
it a little
a little william blake i don't know if
you're familiar with his beautiful
paintings
but uh and his vision his moral vision
as well and so i wanted it to
have that same almost pulsating
sense of mystery of possibility
so that's how it came to be yeah it's so
wonderfully evocative and and it's not
it's not like you know our younger
listeners won't know about what this is
but you know tv guide uh
used to be this journal that you'd get
uh maybe in the impulse purchase section
of the supermarket exactly although you
know maybe some of us subscribed i'm not
i'm not judging
uh but uh but this is no tv guy this
this is
this is a book of of great artistic
beauty but also
of great um uh of great mystery as if
as if a puzzle to be solved uh upon
reading it
and uh i just found it so uh so
delightful to
come upon these ideas which of course i
know a lot of the signs
even some of the basics of fields
outside of my
domain of expertise which is
astrophysics i know enough to be
dangerous
uh or to think i know uh but but hearing
the
the weaving through as you just
described of kind of what it means to be
a possible world and it could be a
possible
world in time or in space or or in a
forest
or in our own hearts and i think it's
it's so lovely and lyrical to
to go on this journey and to realize
that you
like carl i always think of you and you
know this first time we've met so to
speak
but i've i've always thought of carl as
sort of born with this
artistic soul and i do want to get into
how you can become
um or model carl because you know some
of the
some of the conversation we'll have
today will be sort of in a father's day
uh episode uh vignette that will
mirror sasha's mother's day episode uh
but but in this case
you know how can people become more like
that i think of carl as
almost having this proto-natural ability
but maybe he worked on it
but on you i know that you didn't you
weren't born a scientist i know that you
weren't
your degree in background as an in
science um but
i almost feel like as carl became kind
of a card-carrying artist
that you've graduated to this level i
don't know if i'll give you a phd even
an honorary phd yet but
how do you feel about that side of you
that do you feel like
um you've you've been around scientists
and you've learned so much science and
you've innovated
scientific ideas without equations but
that you now
do you consider yourself a scientist now
no i'm not a scientist i don't have the
credentials
i have vast uh
nebulae of ignorance you know
my my scientific knowledge
is uh is is just not commensurate with a
scientist
but that i feel has in a way been
uh an asset because i'm
i'm a writer yeah i'm a hunter-gatherer
of stories
and a writer and so um
just imagine what it would be like to
spend every day and night
for 19 and a half years with carl sagan
and to be able to ask him any question
that occurred to you fearlessly because
you
knew that he felt so strongly he
believed so strongly in questions
and it was part of his evos never ever
to use his knowledge to wound another
person
or to make them feel small and so there
was no question
i had you know i could fearlessly ask
him any question without
being afraid that he would think i was
stupid
and he treated each one with such
respect
so i guess you could say i had this
astonishing tutorial
with i think one of the greatest
teachers who ever lived
yeah and that's you know that's about
the size of my
and i'm a reader so and i do uh
you know i i do try to keep myself
abreast
of what's happening in science and it's
no secret that
cosmos the the original first season or
first
series you know influence uh at the time
you know a good fraction of the entire
population of the world
uh some say upwards of a billion people
uh were exposed to the messages
of of true scientists uh and you were uh
you you played a role in that and a huge
role and you continue to do so
and i see you as yes as as not just the
hunter gatherer but but you're
you're kind of this you know rosetta
stone which you you show in the book
but where you interpret between these
different disciplines as i always joke
you know
how do you know a scientist is outgoing
you know he looks at your shoes when he
talks to you instead of his own
but carl was nothing like that and yeah
and you're the vivacious
opposite of of that stereotype so how
does it feel to to have that
um have that impact on humanity
is it is it a terrible burden also ann
because i worry
everything that you say is carried with
such weight uh because it has the
impermanent or
of your of your career and carl as well
yeah no i think i think it's a it's an
enormous privilege which i take
seriously
but i don't feel it's ever a burden
it's an honor and it's a source of
tremendous gratification because you
know i hear from people
in every country the new cosmos as well
as the previous ones
uh is is being shown in 172 countries
and so you know i think for all of us
who've been yelling at the tv
news for so many years for me
it's a tremendous outlet not
to yell back but to be able to present
something that i hope is more compelling
so yeah no i i i i
caution but uh but also a sense of what
a privilege this
is yeah you know as i was listening to
the book
um and as we'll get into and we talk
about the meaning and value of books and
i always you know before i met sasha
would would hearken to carl's
um great quote about the magic of of
authorship and of writing a book and
that you hear hear the author's voice
and he was writing in a time before
there were audiobooks on the
level that we have today at least uh and
literally we hear your voice
and and today i was listening and and
your and the co-reader of the book
um but you know when i was listening to
it and there's a pastor you say like
what happens if some long dormant virus
becomes
active and causes a global pandemic and
and i was like well
you know if i had read that you know
heard that six months ago
you know that's maybe less likely than
an asteroid hitting the earth
but you know but again having this uh
prescience
sometimes i i do feel like because
scientists are so revered
if you look up you know the other day i
saw something and this show is
completely non-political i always say i
love astronomy because there's no
there's no republican constellations and
democratic asteroids you know it's
it should be a politics uh free zone not
not
academic freedom free zone it should be
you know vigorous debate
but i like to have a little vestige of
relief from politics to give my
listeners that that that
expanse expansiveness opportunity to
just get out of their shells
but now we're just inundated by by you
know we can't ignore science i i was
joking the other day that
you know flattening the curve and um and
you know these exponential curves
have taught more people about calculus
than all of ap calculus and
really and but but as a scientist i see
things like you know 77 noble
laureates come out to say x y and z
about uh you know which
which um treatment should be taken or
which approach to opening up the economy
etc
um as a scientist you know did do you
feel like carl
felt it it could be a burden because i
know that it is a great privilege i'm
sure it is a great privilege
to do what you do but the fact that that
scientists are are looked up to
so highly it is a great privilege it
comes with some responsibility and and
i i would just think i would be curious
to know how how you know
he reacted and how you react knowing
that your words have this tremendous
power
and that people are looking to you and
looking to scientists for answers and
sometimes
maybe we can't provide them i have never
met
a more conscientious citizen
who took his or her
duty to
his or her fellow citizens than carl
and that was the fundament that was the
basis
that moved him because
he really believed that the knowledge
that he'd been fortunate enough to
acquire
belongs to all of us and he also
believed
that the failure of education
the the that
segregation of scientists
apart from the rest of us
with their own special jargon that is
unintelligible
to us was a threat to democracy
especially in our society which is
utterly dependent
on science and high technology and there
was a
final layer to that and as he used to
say
when you're in love you want to tell the
world
that's how he felt about the revelations
of science
that's how he felt about the universe
that science reveals
he wanted everyone to at least
have a chance to experience that soaring
feeling
and that's what motivated him well and
and just uh
last kind of touching upon the the
intersection of love and carl
and your life we're talking is uh june
5th we're recording this
um and in the book you talk about the
special date june 3rd
1977 right can you say something about
that
and and that and the science of love if
you will
well june 3rd was very special june 1st
is to me personally
my most holy day of the year because
that was the day that carl and i after
knowing each other and working together
for years
discovered that we were in love with
each other
and it was only after that eureka moment
that i went to a new york university
to have my brain waves all of the
signals
that could be recorded from my body
uh recorded to be placed on board
voyagers one and two and i meditated for
an hour
while being centrally deprived i had a
mental itinerary
and i tried to be unselfish for most of
it
and to to tell
the punitive beings of other worlds and
times
uh the history of our planet
its geological history its biological
history
our own human history and at the
end i saved myself
the joy of meditating
about the meaning of love and what it
felt
for a 27 year old woman to be
truly madly in love
and the love we feel for our families
and each other
i mean it was i tried to make it as
expansive
as possible but i couldn't help
but frat that i realized that my
own life had finally taken
this sudden and magnificent course
and of course they're now on board the
voyagers the most distant objects
ever touched by human hands and they
have a
projected shelf life of 5
billion with a b 5 billion years
i still can't wrap my head around 40
years later
i still can't wrap my head around it you
know that
meditation has become very very popular
in recent years
there's all sorts of apps there's all
sorts of uh what's what tickles me is
that they're people like sam harris
who's very much in the carl sagan
tradition
and he's got an app and and he's got a
course and a podcast and
and so forth and they talk about this
this
attribute of meditation called meta
which means literally loving kindness
and it sounds like you pre-saged that
you know by about 40 years so what's
funny is
i i know that meditation has gotten
really popular i actually had on dr
judd brewer who is a meditation i mean
an addiction specialist md phd at brown
university
had him on and he has an app and he has
a program for quitting smoking and
cravings and addictions
and um and he talks about this yeah this
meta
a trait of meditation and um and just a
side note i realized that
this was maybe getting out of hand when
the rapper p diddy
you know puff daddy came out with a
meditation course but i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna get into that
every every person's entitled to their
meditation that's right
but uh and thinking about it uh and kind
of synthesizing
that when i heard you and read
about this experience of sending and
transmitting your brain waves
um i started to think well is there an
addictive quality to to
love and um is it possible that you know
food is necessary but you know some of
us struggle with
addictions to it maybe perhaps or bad
bad food
smoking obviously other substances uh is
love perhaps you know
the only non-uh destructive craving a
type of addiction that one can
uh can continue to use without ill
effect what do you feel about the
addictive quantum qualities of love
because it comes through so resonantly
in your writing
well addictive is a very freighted word
sure
and it immediately suggests dysfunction
impairment and love is the opposite to
me
love is a way
of growing and of finding
you know it's it's like the universe you
can explore it
for your whole life and never come to a
wall
if you're lucky no and so to me
love it doesn't belong with the
addiction metaphor
because love that's what we need we all
need it so few of us get the love we
need
and i think that accounts for a lot of
our problems
and the most important love of all is
the love you experience
in childhood it at as infant
and beyond i mean i feel like
the love that my parents gave me it
wasn't perfect
you know i have major issues with my mom
but but you know to be honest
but her i knew she loved me and i
never in my whole life had any reason to
doubt for a moment
of my father's 99 years that he
loved me and he was a genius in love so
so i felt that that love
as to quote a brilliant
philosopher named chad lucero i felt
that that
love was the protective garment
that i put on in childhood and that has
protected me my whole life
even from it's even helped me through
the worst times of my life and um
so yeah um for it
yeah i think it also comes with risks
like anything else and
you know i was thinking well just to
touch upon you know since since you are
the first mother-daughter duo in history
on the into the impossible podcast
i think i might have said to sasha
although i'm not sure um there's a joke
about why do
grandparents and grandkids get along so
well and the answer is they have a
common enemy
and i think it's true no parent is
perfect we all fail those of us that are
blessed to have children
we all fail but you know to me they
represent you know an ultimate form
of time travel in the following sense
speaking of sam harris as i did a few
minutes ago
he has um he has a kind of a thought
exercise taken from another
research scientist in this book waking
up uh and it's about
uh you know the consideration of the
following situation
if you could transport teleport yourself
to another world a possible world that
we call mars
and and you would uh be perfectly
reassembled but your all your atoms
would be teleported there
uh and and you'd get there perfectly
healthy and everyone who's been on this
trip has said it's it's perfectly safe
and healthy and you'll be what you'll
love it you love mars
um you put you have to push this button
and then the last memory you have when
you arrive on mars is that you just push
this green button on earth
and uh and now you've got this whole new
button but there's a catch
which is that uh all your atoms on earth
have to be obliterated as soon as you
push the button
to avoid you know having an extra copy
of you floating around
and the scientist in that sam is quoting
asked the question you know how many
people would push it
and isn't this basically like suicide
you know in one sense
even though you're confident in the
science behind it and the process could
you know
accepting we don't know if we can
actually do this
and i started thinking you know would i
push that button and i started to feel
like maybe
i don't need to because you know i do
have children and children are kind of
you know what's we're only going to live
a certain amount of time i think very
few of us can name our great great great
grandparents right
what their first name was um and very
few of us will meet our great great
grandchildren
but uh but the hope is that you instill
within them this kind of
um uh memes or you know some kind of
code that they will live on uh that
carry on some of your ideas of course
you want them to be independent
so um do you consider children to be
another type of possible world
as well that that can transport you know
some of your
essence into into the future
that's exactly what they are and i agree
with you completely brian
because you know i i was so lucky
as i said because i not only had my
parents but on my maternal grandmother
and grandfather
i was very close to and
i was so lucky to know them because they
were
very different than culturally
than i am but they exemplified
the values the real values of their
of their belief system which they didn't
want to impose on anyone else
which was really amazing and
uh you know they're long gone and yet
they're in my mind and my heart all the
time and
probably almost daily and
the things that i learned from them and
my parents
even most more so with my parents are
with me
with every heartbeat and that's why
the abuse of a child is
a crime a misfortune of such
such it's a calamity because
you know if you look at the other
organisms the other life forms on earth
they're you know we can see in them
that their primary job is to
reproduce to survive to reproduce
so that their dna gets passed on you can
see all kinds of behaviors on their part
that is designed by evolution by time in
the environment
to produce certain behaviors
well it's this we're no different and
when you are a good strong link
in the chain of generations as my
grandparents were
and as my parents were to me
and then i you know but that's your
that's your sacred trust
is to be the same for your children and
your grandchildren
and so you know if you think of the
generations of humanity
if you think of you know if you could
somehow really visualize them
that's been that's always been before we
were human
before we were mammals that was our
charge and so i agree completely
i wouldn't push that button to go to
mars
because i am completely part of the
fabric
of this world and i
you know i i don't i don't think there's
any other world
that of which i know or i could be
happier
yeah you speak about it in the book and
and even even when you talk about the
connection between a grain of pollen and
and this vast
network that involves uh you know insect
floral partnerships
and you think about the genetic
imperative of of these things which are
not adamant i don't think anyone say
you talk about super determinism in the
book but i don't think anyone say you
know the grain of pollen
is is particularly conscious of its role
in some darwinian
sense and yet it's doing this and it's
shielded as you
colorfully put it you know you can fire
it out of the barrel of a gun
and it will do it and what parent
wouldn't you know step in front of a gun
to protect their their
their offspring it's just uh it's it's
so lovely i i do want to say
you know in science we have a tradition
you know unfortunately
for most of it it was very patriarchal
it was very male centered
absolutely we're doing a tremendous
amount here and elsewhere
in our community both to broaden the
participation diversity
of science to include women um and
minorities of all kinds and
and they're contributing such vibrancy
to our to our contributions
uh scientists uh however you know
because of
the internet i am able to track my phd
genealogy
back 17 generations whereas i only know
my you know great grandfather his name
and so we can actually go really far
back so i know his name
he lived in the 1590s he died in the
1590s
his last friedrich leibniz was our my
first member of my
of my people and wow that's really an
illustrious sarah it
is and you know what's so delightful to
me it is that now
i recently met my graduate student darcy
barron is a professor at the university
of new mexico
and she has a graduate student too who's
now in the 19th and 20th generations uh
uh and her graduate student kayla
hopefully will someday be a professor so
we'll be able to go 20
now when i look at that uh it reminded
me uh when
when in chapter in chapter six of of
cosmos possible worlds it's called
the man of a trillion worlds and kind of
in this theme
of mentorship as you know it could be
matriarchal it could be patriarchal it
could be
dynastic in a sense that carl was very
deeply shaped by these two men uh gerald
kuiper
and uh harold urie and i just want to
focus on harold yuri for a second and
then we'll get into
into kuiper because i think he's the
more interesting of the two uh
mentors that carl had in the sense but
harold uri we are our chemistry building
here in san diego
is named after him and he had a deep
influence of course with his phd student
stanley miller
uh and they had the famous enormous yeah
miller yuri experiment which you uh to
discuss in the book
but uh what touched me so much is the is
the is the obituary that that carl wrote
for
harold urie in that first uh journal
that's really interdisciplinary called
icarus that carl
started and and uh co-founded and his
obituary
kind of reminded me of almost like what
a son would say about his father on on
his death and and it's appropriate for
this father's day kind of component or
season he said a scientist about about
harold uri
one of the founders of ucsd's chemistry
department
said a scientist who transcended
disciplinary boundaries
and who helped carry us to the moon and
to the planets
and about uh uh dr kreiper uh
these two scientists were rivals in a
sense which i never appre i never really
realized of course we all
hated each other yeah and and i want to
talk about that the adversarial nature
of science
there's not an at least in a healthy
parent-child relationship there
shouldn't be an adversarial relationship
in adolescence there should be a little
bit oh really can you can you
say why say why oh because it's just
like i you know if you watch
if you study birds and you know cornell
uh university has this ornithology
center
with a webcam in the nests of various
birds and i
watch uh these birds uh
so i wish i could think of the species
i'm sorry i'm blocking on it at the
moment
but i have watched these birds you know
hatch and then become chicks
and then start to venture out
on a branch that's maybe
uh 30 feet above the ground
and you see the birds look down
and then they look up and they think for
a moment and then they run back
to their nest and they keep doing this
but every time they come back to the
nest
they yell at their parents and then you
it's amazing it's exactly like
being a parent uh i know a 14 year old
or 15 year old
and they come back and they yell at the
parents and they flap their wings at the
parents
and they mess up the nest and they raise
this
huge human cry then they calm down
and the next day they inch out on the
branch
they look down no no
come back start the same fight over and
over again
and then one day they just
go out on the branch and this time they
fly away
wow and i saw that i thought you know
and and it's true i when i think of what
i did to my parents when i was a
teenager
and how i must have tested their
patients how i must have frightened
them with my behavior with my
it was you know selfishness
um lack of consideration
lack of awareness of their feelings
um arguments about ridiculous things
thunderstorms of rage all of that
is normal and it's because that's how we
separate from our parents that's how we
fight off that desire to crawl back into
their arms and stay there forever
and you know this seems to be
cross-cultural
it seems to be something that
every different kind of society has at
one time
ritualized come to grips with you know
send him into the forest for two years
you know
many different variations it's natural
and once you understand that it's not
personal
it's natural you know it's like all of
those bubbles coming to the surface
of resentments of fears of
hurts and so you know it's just
i mean if you're a genius of love like
my dad was
you you always show love
no matter how provoked you are
and then what happens which is so
amazing what happened to me
was that even though it was the 60s and
wild and i was wild
i had such love from my father because
he had loved me through everything
that i you know the the primary
cons thought in my mind was i can't do
anything that would hurt him
and so the you know the really brilliant
thing to do
is to understand and to love
i love that furry's genius of love i
think i might use it as a subtitle for
this episode
uh harry dreanne harry drian the
original
and his mother jilly all right well
it'll be lovely to get pictures of them
for to put in the video so handsome
yeah so so speaking of love and and
science
now the um i've heard it described and i
like this description that you know
that um teaching is an act of love and
in that
you can't simultaneously be fearful you
know
of physical unsafety or or danger or
um and be learning and transmitting you
can't i love you so much you know like
anger
and you know i'm so angry at you now
learn the uh geodesic deviation equation
of you know it just can't happen
obviously the love should be platonic
that goes without saying but um
but in terms of science it's hard
sometimes as a
parent so to speak i'm not meaning to be
paternalistic but there is that kind of
relationship
you know where peop you know people go
to the funerals of their advisors just
like they would go to their parents yes
you know or god forbid you know if
someone younger than them passes away
um and and i've had to deal with with
aspects of that including mental health
issues including things like suicide of
people very close to me and it affected
me
and in the science world a mentor
committed suicide
and it's uh it's still devastating 10
years later and i look at it and i say
you know science has this kind of
heterodox structure
in that it has this loving aspect or
should be loving
platonically so between uh mentor mentee
you know protege so to speak but also
between the scientists themselves
fighting and squabbling adversarially i
mean i do
believe that you uh would might agree
with the statement that you know science
is adversarial and
you talk about kuiper and uri almost as
like you know and carl being kind of
like the child of divorced parents
i wonder if if you could take us through
that relationship obviously
you know uh yuri went on to kind of uh
had a much
vaster scientific reputation kuiper's
ideas i think
are more influential to this day
that's perfect yeah so um so what do you
make of this
adversarial relationship that scientists
have to have between them
themselves but also you know it's like
my i love my student
until she gets her phd and then i'm
competing with her for funds and the
same nsf
and she's writing papers and like we
should be critical how do you
how would you advise you know balancing
this relationship that's
on one hand acting as as loving pursuers
of truth
but another hand as acting like you know
sobs you're really
criticizing an adversarialization well
you know what everything you've said
brian is
ring so true to me
you know as i think of what carl would
say about the two men
and what they meant to him and uh
you know yuri
was a very tough guy he grew up in a
really hard scrabble
childhood and you know he worked in a
mining camp as a tutor
until until his employer said you should
go to college
brilliant and he did go to college and
then he
you know won the nobel prize and i mean
he was
he was and so carl understood where he
was coming from
and he was very hard on carl
uh if carl you know who was working in
his laboratory
and uh thrilled to be there you know if
carl raised
questions about the possibilities of
extraterrestrial life for instance even
though
yuri himself as you mentioned
uh with miller created really
the first and only i think experiment
uh in in in the study of life
the origin of life elsewhere and
carl i guess because he was so hungry
for the knowledge that yuri could give
him
uh he took
the harshness uh
appropriately he understood that that
was this man's
personality kyper was
very different very very different
keiper when carl would tell me of the
rookie mistakes
he made in kuiper's laboratory and
you know foolish mistakes that only
someone who
who really had a lot to learn with me
tiger was
always so kind about it and
but kaiper had his own quirks
you know he he didn't work well
with others uh he could work
well with carl and they could become
true friends when carl
matured as a scientist but
uh he you know he had his own
he also came up the hard way uh from a
poor family in holland
but he had familial support
his father who was impoverished a
poor tailor managed to
get the money together to buy him a
telescope when he was still a child
and um so i i i think that
in some way i'm guessing accounts for
part of the difference
but and then there were other times when
carl when carl became
famous uh i think
yuri did him some very
profound injuries yeah and
yet carl loved him even then
because he he could understand
and why are scientists you know i love
the idea that
i couldn't find a single example of
one scientist killing another scientist
over a scientific idea which i think is
something very special i have an idea
for a fiction book where
there's four people in the running for a
nobel prize and one murders the other
one
and so that there's something because
you can't get it posthumously well no no
because only three people can win it so
no yes yes but also when someone's dead
that's right no matter how great they
are you can't get them
the prize yeah which somehow has still
stopped them from giving it to jocelyn
bell burnell
that's pretty much alive and margaret
burbidge was anyway i don't know and
marvin political
great market purpose yes was great in
every way yes yes another another person
whom carl had tremendous
love and admiration for anyway so get
back to
kuiper and yuri um i guess
you know the fact is is that all
scientists are also primates
and um and and and indulge
especially in a kind of uh
you know because of the male
predominantly male hierarchy of science
for the first 300 years
um it seems to me that there was a lot
of
dominance hierarchy stuff going on
the exclusion of women the exclusion
of of non-europeans and non-americans
all of those things the way that you
know
an indian mathematical genius could be
treated
or a a great indian scientist could be
treated i mean this is all part of that
same
profound toxic illness
and uh but miller and yuri
you know in the end uh i just feel that
that miller i'm sorry not miller yuri
i met a kuiper in europe i believe that
kuiper
was a visionary in
in the greatest sense i mean we owe him
that first scientific realization
that solar systems were not rare
that the other stars you were seeing in
the sky
had worlds of their own uh this he he
wrote this in 1949
and how how right he was
he didn't live to see this enormous
vindication
um and both of them did play a role in
us getting to the moon but yuri yuri was
really i think possibly more influential
in the idea that the moon would be our
goal
than any other scientist and i i think
about that as you said you know
scientists are primates and and and so
forth i also think of scientists as
as very childlike we're we're curious
we're
a little mischievous we're a little
anti-authoritarian we're also very
jealous we're very selfish we're very
petty we're very you know conniving
uh just like our wonderful little
blessings in our children
and i wonder if you know at some level
your perspective on i believe it's it's
a responsibility not to be carl sagan i
don't think
many people can be a carl sagan uh
there's there some that come
you know kind of inspiring that mode
including neil degrasse tyson who carl
influenced directly and neil credits as
his
real mentor in this in this field but
you know can a scientist be a
communicator
uh and uh an honest-to-goodness
card-carrying scientist
um in a way that that that carl
at least you know could be inspired by
carl uh by what he did
but you know still maintaining a
prodigious output like carl did i think
that's very hard
so i guess the question i'm asking you
is is there an obligation for scientists
my colleagues such as such as myself and
others
to do communication to work actually to
spend a little bit of their time
learning how to communicate how to write
how to how to present
how to give public speeches how to
engage with congress and and the media
um we don't spend any time with that and
yet i feel like it's the most important
meta skill in our skill stack and i i
teach it personally to my graduate
students but
not all my colleagues agree with me
where do you cleave in this in this
this discussion oh i think it's vital to
science
i think it's not just vital to society
i think the idea of a scientific
priesthood
is uh sick because
uh it's it's you know first of all
because of the
astonishing power that science has
how can you aspire to have a democratic
society
and and decide that the scientists
can be in one place surrounded by a
great wall
i i really do i know i declare my bias
but um i really think that carl more
than any single person
einstein was a great communicator uh
but that was a very even longer ago
and before media um or
you know really had uh its grip
on everyone's imagination and everyone's
day and so i think that carl who
got was really took a lot of abuse and
punishment
for going on the tonight show
and writing for parade magazine and
uh trying to get the message out in
every way he could
uh even though as actually michael
shermer
did the paper the really good paper
on the on on carl's
600 refereed
peer-reviewed scientific papers
now think about 600 papers yeah while
he's editing icarus
right well he's you know uh nasa
planetary society while he's an
investigator
on every single spacecraft mission of
the united states
from the birth of nasa until his death
as well as a participant
in some of the russian voyages of
exploration
while he's winning the pulitzer prize
for one of his dozen
great books while he is being
in my view the greatest husband who ever
could have been
and a truly great father and a truly
great son
you know that's what that's that's what
really amazes me about carl
is that for me he's the existence
theorem
he's the proof that we can be
100 functioning on
every level flourishing on every level
none at the expense of the other
and that's another reason why his life
gives me so much hope did he have any
you know kind of
a workflow or tactics and tricks and
habits and hacks as they would say
nowadays
did you and what are yours actually well
mine
um you know i don't do
as much as carl did but for instance
in writing and producing and directing
cosmos
uh these last two seasons uh you know
that was uh and writing the book at the
same time
yeah and then having uh miss calamity
with sam my son almost died during the
course of the whole thing
um you know i don't know if i had a hack
but i had a passion
and the passion is what moves me
the times the war on science
the contempt for science
uh the destruction of some of our great
scientific
agencies those are the things that
really have propelled me and then
you know the great good fortune of
working with 986
other people on this most recent season
of cosmos
so many of them from the previous season
because we
love to work with each other just i mean
and just that you know
to be a 70 year old woman who was born
at a time and who grew up in a time and
came of age at a time
when i didn't even get to finish a
sentence
when you know the primary form
of entertainment was the humor of how
stupid women were
i mean it was just like that that was it
and so to come to a time
in which i feel like i have been given
much more than even i deserve in my
opportunities to communicate
to be heard uh that's another thing it
gives me so much hope
not that we're there yet and obviously
currently we we know we have so many
rivers to cross
but but to feel that much progress
since my childhood that is
you know one of the that's another thing
that gives me the energy
to do this i want to ask you in the last
couple of minutes before we turn to our
uh standard questions that we ask of all
of our uh beloved guests on the show
um not what carl would think but what do
you think what does ann
think about the so-called eerie silence
the fact that we have been undergoing
the seti
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
including a search now here located at
uc san diego by my colleague
shelly wright whose team of she's got
dozens of people working on this an
optical seti search
and she's carrying very much in the
tradition of carl sagan
i hope you guys can meet someday um but
what do you make of this we're in the
60th year
actually now and uh we've had on a spate
of
um of guests on the podcast paul davies
uh greg
james benford and others who have really
kind of
spoken almost as if they're resigned
that the silence is
deafening and permanent and i want to
ask you as
a as a person is is this a a you know a
point of depression for you is this
something that
you know the lack of of communication or
messaging from
any other civilization or knowledge of a
life form outside of what we have on
earth
or is it hopeful in a sense i've heard
people say it gives them hope that
you know humanity will protect itself so
where do you andrea not not
carl i don't know how i'd love to answer
this question but why does it give them
hope
well because i think they they feel that
that human beings will come to the
realization that this is it
that we're living in the only time and
space in the universe history
perhaps uh although it's impossible to
know and that we will that take that
as a as a uh with gratitude as you just
spoke so lovingly about the trait of
gratitude which i think is so rare and
so beautiful
uh but you're grateful to have the
opportunity i'm like that humanity will
see our isolation as a privilege
and therefore take good better care of
the environment i'm not saying i don't
i don't agree with that because actually
i don't think the people who just spoil
our
environment and and brutalize each other
they are thinking about whether or not
uh
life exists elsewhere in the universe
nor would they care
i mean the point is life is here and
they don't care
so you know i don't think so
but i have i do you know the fear made
paradox you know
where are they that doesn't i don't
think it's a paradox
and this is why maybe in my ignorance
maybe if i knew more i wouldn't feel
this way
but um we've only had
the ability to receive
radio signals for 125 years something
like that
something on that order yeah even less
so if we'd been bombarded by radio
signals
anytime in the previous four and a half
billion years
we wouldn't know anything about it and
so
here we are you know we're celebrating
frank drake's birthday his 90th birthday
yes
that's right and um you know so i i
consider him the father
of seti and uh his
i believe uh you know
he began doing that 60 years ago
six years that's nothing
moreover we think
because we discovered radio signals over
a hundred years ago
that that's the way to do it it's a
failure of the imagination
because it doesn't permit
what could happen in the next 60 years
what we could discover
how we could you know there there are
conceivably other ways to communicate
and very likely other ways to
communicate that we haven't even tumbled
to
and said the search seti
yes there are people conducting this
search
but they have only examined a tiny
fraction
of the sky put them all together it's
not even
a really significant part of the sky
so you know just because it hasn't
happened
yet or because you know a couple of
generations of scientists have been
looking
that really doesn't mean anything to me
i just look at the sheer
number of worlds in the universe
even just in our galaxy and i think
that you know we just don't know
um i also think that there are
tantalizing
intimations of past life
on mars will they turn out to be
stromatolites or
just something else geological
um possibly but
you know it seems to me that let's go
let's go to enceladus and plunge through
the frozen poles
to get to this subterranean ocean
let's go uh let's do a lot more
exploration and searching before we come
to any conclusions on the subject
yes as jill tarter who's a friend of the
center for human imagination has been on
the show
as well as her biographer uh sarah
scholes has been on the show recently
well the book is called making contact
and of course it makes a reference to
your a wonderful book
and film of the same name contact yes um
i wanna
just indulge it because it's it's maybe
the one chance i ever get if i could ask
a personal question
which is um you know all people uh as
you know i'm a practicing jew i wouldn't
say i'm an orthodox jew that i
don't want to saddle the orthodox with
any burdens in that way but i
i do practice i do observe the sabbath i
don't work i don't send emails i don't
do things like that
um but every day i doubt the existence
of god
i don't i don't i view myself as a
devout atheist as a sorry devout
agnostic
that i'm a practicing slip there yeah
exactly right
and that you know if you're an atheist
uh you don't go to the same
synagogue that richard dawkins doesn't
go to you may be you know an agnostic in
your and
what you tell people but you're actually
not going to you're not practicing
you're not doing anything that
that richard dawkins doesn't do but but
as i said you know everyone i know
even my rabbi will will say you know
that that he has doubts
and and and great thinkers have always
said this and that's why we have this
term faith
um do you ever doubt the secular
uh explanations for you know the origin
of the universe or
or perhaps do you doubt do you ever
doubt the non-existence
of a supernatural being you know earlier
in our wonderful conversation i'm so
enjoying it
you mentioned the fact that the
scientists you knew
were anti-authoritarian in politics well
how could they not be if they're
scientists
because you know those five simple rules
of the methodology of science say
question authority no arguments from
authority
and so my feeling is this
uh i'm a great admirer of
spinoza rick spinozza who
whose story we tell in the new season of
cosmos which will be on fox september
22nd
yes and um i think
spinoza's insight that
about miracles is something that i have
taken to heart
personally and that is do not look for
god in miracles
because god is really the sum
total of the physical laws of the
universe god is
nature and miracles
are violations of
the laws of nature and god is
best apprehended in the laws of nature
now spinoza was writing this before
newton think of it i mean they've
already been kepler and galileo
and the idea that spignosa
wrote this before some of the most
uh revolutionary laws of nature were
even discovered
is to me something i could never get
over
and so do i question my secular
beliefs i absolutely question everything
but most of all i try to protect myself
from false pattern recognition which i
think is one of our
greatest strengths pattern recognition
the underside of one of our greatest
strengths false pattern recognition
confirmation bias right confirmation
bias is counting the hits
so i hope that i am open-minded
and open-hearted enough so that
if something were to happen
like for instance quantum physics which
uh in many ways is a step beyond
classical physics then i would be open
to it
but i don't question i don't
question the importance
and the magnificence of
nature and for me
you know i told i spoke briefly about my
grandparents at the beginning
they were the most profoundly observant
people i have ever known and yet
i saw what it was like to be profoundly
observant
they were orthodox to
even suffer because of their orthodoxy
and yet to embody
what i believe in my secular way
is the essence of the goodness
that our sacred books were trying to
invoke in us
that's you know so i respect
and would never never tell anybody what
to believe
but i my own belief is simply
that since we live in a
uh we are lucky enough to live in a
diverse society
it's very hard uh once you
have witnessed something of the beauty
and creativity and genius
of other cultures to
pick one culture pick one
uh system of beliefs and say
that's where i build my church you know
i can't do that
because you know there's another voice
in my head which comes from
science which is saying remember you
might be wrong
and that's the glory of science is
saying we'll give
our highest awards to the one who can
prove
that our most cherished beliefs are
incorrect
that's its power i think yeah i always
say
it's the hardest the hardest path to
strike is the one down
the middle and the reason that society
is so polarized is because it's actually
easier to be a zealot
a religious zealot or a political zealot
it's always easy to be on one side or
the other
but to strike that middle ground a
scientist must do in order to be
dispassionate and follow the evidence
wherever it leads
as you and carl often say that's so
it's so difficult because you're at this
um at this inflection point this
unstable point of equilibrium that you
could pummel
either way at the slightest push but i
think walking cleaving to that middle
ground
it's both uh it's both challenging but
it's rewarding as well
well it's being realistic about your
true circumstances in the universe
you're not at the center it doesn't
revolve around you
right you know you're just part of it
you're part of it
you're not at the center no matter what
you do although i have to you know take
that up with some of my colleagues who
still think they are i'm not going to
get political with my colleagues right
now uh i do want to
finish i know you're so busy and i just
want to uh you know
take the opportunity because how often
do i get this chance to speak to
a luminaries such as yourself to ask you
the questions i ask all my guests
into the impossible and one of them will
be laughingly easy
for you to answer i expect although who
knows the first one
may not be but it's um it kind of goes
along with a little bit of what sasha
talks about in her book which is the
power of rituals
and that the transmission orally and
written and it involves something in
hebrew called an ethical will or a zava
ah
and this is a document that communicates
not material wealth
uh but but spiritual if you will but i
don't know if you like that word i don't
particularly care
i like it okay so what values what
wisdom
and traditions for the future
generations would you like to put in
your ethical will
in my ethical will i would like to
i guess the first paragraph would be
do justly walk humbly love mercy
from micah my god yes micah
that would be my first uh and then i
would say
but not with your god right you would
say with science just walk humbly
okay period walk humbly
then the next one would be
work for a world and for a time
when our species values
the things we need most to live
our air our water our climate
each other value those
above money value those above money
before it's too late
we do have a window here but the window
is closing and we have to
you know i look at all of the
isms on this planet all the different
modes of human social organization
and the modes of distribution of wealth
and not one of them thinks
in the time scale of 10 years
let alone a century or a thousand years
but the time scales
that science speaks in
are up to 13.8 billion years
and our legacy our birthright on this
planet
is 4 billion years old and so
learn to be a great strong link
in the chain of life that you all of you
me
we all go all the way back to that and
beyond
to the hearts of distant stars
so remember that and keep it holy
lovely another question that i ask
based on the fact that we are here at
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at uc san diego
pertains to sir arthur c clarke's uh
book 2001
and in that book uh featured in the film
by stanley kubrick
uh and and this is particularly
pertinent to you who is an author
a producer a writer a director um so
like like arthur c clarke i want to ask
you this question
uh you'll recall of course the famous
monoliths that are of course
in particular locations around the solar
system uh
including the serengeti plane and the
moon or the earth's moon
they're meant to be sort of devices
maybe warnings maybe
encapsulations or time capsules that
reflect or make a statement or perhaps a
warning you know don't come here we've
irradiated the planet maybe i don't know
or don't develop this particular type of
virus
whatever uh but what would you put uh on
your monolith and
like i said i you you're the only guest
i've ever had and probably will ever
have
who's actually sent a billion five
billion year long time capsule into the
universe
uh which which generated so much human
interest and actually
i think nucleated the entire field of
things like
world music and and kind of soundscapes
uh for the very first time in history so
anyway what would you put on a model an
equation some people have told me they'd
put certain equations on
what would you what would you put on
your monolith to last for all eternity
if you got a mulligan you could do it
again okay well
uh i think you know because
i think i want to say frank drake's
siren scientific hieroglyphics on the
voyager record
um because it tells
where we are and what we figured out
and uh it speaks in a way about
human achievement and it's elegant and
beautiful
um no not that no not that one that's
the arecibo message
oh it's the uh frank shakespeare sibo
message okay yes
which one i'm i'm talking about the
cover of the of the voyager record
oh the actual cover of it okay yeah the
golden good disc
yes just because i you know i probably
really need
more time to think of something which is
more
responsive in to your question
but because that's really one of my
favorite things you know just because it
conveys
so much information without depending
on one or another of our
cultural languages and i just think it's
so elegant
it tells you where where we are
intellectually as well as our location
in terms of our son's relationship
yeah a dozen or 14 nearest pulsars it's
brilliant
and and in that sense i feel like that
was a voyage to the inside of what it
means to be a human being that that
record the golden disc the voyager
record is almost a message to ourselves
more than any other
uh species that might encounter it the
last
question that i'm going to ask is going
the opposite direction backwards in time
so this is the into the impossible
podcast and it's
named after arthur c clarke's third law
which says
this first law says any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
yes his second law is me too
his second law is for any uh for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
and his third law was the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and i want to ask you what mysterious
aspect of your life as a 20 year old as
a 30 year old perhaps
as a young person i have a very big
young
young listenership what thing perplexed
you
until you did it and made it possible
wow well that's a really profound
question and uh
i want to really i don't know if i can
come up with as good an
answer as that question is um
and so many things occur to me for one
thing
you know for me as a much younger woman
it was frightening for me to speak in
public
it was because
my heart would be pounding and i part i
think it was the desire
so desperate to be heard and feeling
unheard but uh you know that was
something
that was a frontier for me
and and it's changed very much over the
decades that i've been
uh permitted to speak uh another thing
was of course science itself because
uh i had a profoundly alienating
experience in junior high school which
we
memorialized in the novel contact
and uh a trauma
and you know it was that's another
reason why it was so
amazing because that trauma
sent me uh away from mathematics and
science
even though up to that time i've been a
very good student and i've been very
interested in both
it really wasn't until i discovered the
pre-socratic philosophers
when i was a student uh the inventors of
science
who were the first people to say
uh we can't use this shorthand for
our ignorance that the gods did it
we everything has a cause which can be
discovered
and so i was pa and that that was the
beginning for me and then of course
you know being with carl made it
possible
for me to begin to understand
those aspects of scientific discovery
that i had been so alienated from
so that was a huge thing and i guess
you know uh most personally uh
my parents were married for 66 years
until my mother's death
and uh but it was 66
years of you know arguing and
a lot of uh conflict but they were you
know
and the fact that they stayed together
was meaningful to us but
it was really and i i thought
that love sustained
enduring love a love that could
always reach higher always go
deeper always find new heights
was maybe something that was just a
piece of literary fiction
and learning
learning how to how to be
in that love and then
going every single moment of it being
cognizant
of how lucky i was
for me personally that was great
emotional
psychological uh trip
into the impossible that was really
possible i mean what's the impossible
there are either those are violations of
of the laws of nature or else there are
failures of human imagination and so
you have to try to go there well that's
a lovely way to
conclude our wide-ranging and
fascinating conversation uh with andrean
writer producer of cosmos author of
cosmos possible worlds a phenomenal
book another great contribution and of
course
this uh delightful treat for for me to
have a mother-daughter duo
and i'm looking forward to in a few
years having helena on
so that we'll have the mother daughter
granddaughter edition
of into the impossible yes we have a lot
more
tree and sagans uh and others
who would love to join you so i cannot
wait thank you so much for sharing your
time
uh and it's been a delight chatting with
you it's been a
joy thank you so much brian thank you
anne
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you that are
always open to your suggestions for
future
episodes for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric vieri director brian keating
co-director patrick coleman
associate director produced by stuart
valco